ERIC KOLEDA: The other
layer on the--
TECH PERSON: [INAUDIBLE]
on camera.
ERIC KOLEDA: Whoops.
TECH PERSON: Roll time.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yep, and
then audio down.
Main audio down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC KOLEDA: Hi, and welcome
to Google Apps Unscripted.
My name is Eric Koleda.
I'm a member of the Google
Developer Relations team here,
working on Apps Script.
And with us today, Christian
Moscardi?
Is that how you say it?
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yep.
That's correct.
ERIC KOLEDA: Great.
He's an intern working on our
team for the summer, helping
us out, getting Apps Script--
making it even more awesome
for everybody.
Christian, you want to give us
a little bit of background, I
guess, about maybe who you
are, where you come from?
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Sure.
Well, I go to Columbia
University during the year.
I'm going to be a senior
this coming fall.
And, I'm here on the Developer
Relations team, specifically
with Apps Script for the summer,
working on that,
working on, ultimately, some
code samples that will be
pushed out in the near future.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
One of the things pieces of
feedback we get a lot is that
it really helps to have complete
sample code, a whole
application.
We try to put a lot of little
samples in our docs, little
bit of reference documentation,
or perhaps
little snippets just kind of
throughout our documentation,
to kind of give you an idea
about how to use a very
specific function or feature.
People like to see a larger
end-to-end application,
something that covers more
of the use cases that
they are used to.
So it's great to have you here
helping out with that.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah,
it's great to be here.
It's been a great experience
so far.
I'm excited to be working
on what I'm doing.
ERIC KOLEDA: He was not
obligated to say that.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Not at all.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
Well, we have a ton to cover
today, as well as get into
your questions.
If this is your first time
joining us for Google Apps
Unscripted, there's two ways
you can ask questions.
One is to join the Hangout link,
which I just posted to
the Event Page on Google+ for
this event, as well as the
page on the Google Developers
Live Event Page.
We have two different pages
where you can access the
Hangout link.
So you can either join
us via the Hangout
or, as you can see--
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: The
link is down here?
ERIC KOLEDA: Actually, it's up
at the top, but it may not
have been there when you
loaded the page.
It'll be there now.
But there's also-- then on
this page, there it is.
Join this Hangout.
So you can join there, and we'll
take your live questions
later on in the show.
Or, you can ask via the
Moderator, the Google
Moderator that's embedded just
below the event here, and ask
your questions, if you don't
have a webcam or you don't
feel like getting on air.
We've got some questions
already trickling in.
We'll get to those later
on in the show.
But first, let's talk about
some recent news.
So I think the big one
here is on the blog.
We just published a blog post.
And I mean just--
as in, literally right before
we went on the air.
We published this blog post.
We're happy to announce that
there is a new feature
available in Google
Apps Script.
It's the ability to access the
cursor and selection of the
Active User within a Google
Doc document.
So at Google I/O this year,
one of the big things we
launched was the ability
to write scripts
inside of Google Docs.
And we've seen people kind of
jump on board and start
playing with that.
For right away, they're like,
you know, I really need to get
more interaction.
I need to know what the user's
doing, where they are in the
document, what they
have selected.
And that's something that
we really knew people
we're going to want.
But we had to put the finishing
touches on it.
So it didn't quite
make it for I/O.
But it's out now.
And we think we're really happy
with how it turned out.
And so this blog post links
off to some of the various
reference documentation
around the cursor
and selection object.
But I think even more fun than
looking at some documentation
would be looking at
some examples.
So we published three
different examples
on this blog post.
Do you want lead us through
the first one, Christian?
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Sure.
It's really simple, very
straightforward, just showing
off how you can select a block
of text, say, and then in this
particular script, it's very
simple-- translate it from
English into Spanish.
So it assumes English text and
translate it into Spanish.
But you can imagine, it's very
easy to change those
parameters to whatever
languages you want.
So this is the document here.
And let's say I want to take
this block of text, "automate
workflows such as a document
or expense approvals, order
fulfillment, time tracking and
more"-- hmm, I wonder how you
say that in Spanish?
Oh, look at that.
And there it is, translated
nicely into Spanish for you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So, I think we added a custom
menu item, which is something
that you could at I/O. But now,
rather than just try to
find some texts or do some
manipulation, you now know
what's in the selection.
And that's what makes
this possible.
So, that's a pretty cool one.
Now, if you are also familiar
with what we did at I/O this
year, you may recognize the
term, "Bibstro" or "beepstro,"
depending upon how you choose
to pronounce it--
which is the sample app--
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: This
one's way cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: --built by one of
our engineers, Jonathan.
And this sample app allows you
to do really kind of complex
bibliography management
within a Google Doc.
Now, people have been clamoring
for the source code
as soon as we were there at I/O.
And so, we've released
the source code today.
And I will show you where
all that is later.
And we've also now, with that,
added in the ability for
Cursor and Selection
manipulation.
So now, you can use your
Selection or your Cursor to
help define bibliography
sources.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah.
So the doc's open here.
And the resolution's a little
bit off, it looks like.
Normally your sidebar over here
won't take up a solid
third of your screen.
But this just lets you manage
all the sources that you've
added in, and from there,
update, ultimately, your
bibliography.
And then the Selection feature,
I think, that's been
added in is--
for example, if I highlight
this selection here and
realize, oh, I need to cite this
clause, I would then go
in and say, Add Inline
Citation, what
should pop up a menu.
Yep, here it goes-- which will
allow me to pick one of the
sources that I've added in.
So, clearly this is
from Donald Knuth.
And I cited--
And then you know, there are a
couple other options in here
for a specific bibliography
things.
Oh, can I not reach
the bottom?
ERIC KOLEDA: [INAUDIBLE]
there's resolution.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Again, this
one happened on pretty
much any normal resolution.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's something we
should look into for sure.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Yeah, totally.
But, in any event, if I could
get down there I would then--
maybe if I drag this
up a little bit.
ERIC KOLEDA: Getting into
dangerous territory now.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think you
get the point there.
Basically, he's using
that selection, and
then right in place--
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Exactly.
ERIC KOLEDA: [INAUDIBLE] the
appropriate citation.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
I hit enter?
No, that just closed it out.
ERIC KOLEDA: [INAUDIBLE]
So I think this is--
people have been really
wanting to
play around with this.
And now that the source code's
out there, you can do that.
And when we showed it at I/O,
it didn't have the Selection
capability.
But I think that's something
that really makes it that much
more useful, to really quickly
just drag some text
and say, cite this.
I'm sure in school this would
be extremely useful.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Like, this is something we've
been brainstorming samples
that I could write.
And this is actually one of
the things that came up.
And I was thinking, what can
you do with the sidebar at
Google Docs?
Oh, totally like, a reference
or a citation manager is
something that I know
I would absolutely
want writing papers.
And a lot of my friends at
school would absolutely be
interested in this as well.
So.
ERIC KOLEDA: Very cool.
And so then the third example
that we have here--
this one is a little bit more a
tool for you as a developer,
and less so something that you
would use in the wild.
So it's called Cursor
Inspector.
What essentially it does is it
gives you a sidebar that
allows you to get live updating
information about
what the current state of your
Cursor and Selection is.
So it's actually pretty
challenging to represent a
Cursor and a Selection in a
document model, like the one
that we have in Google Docs
and in the document app.
So we put a lot of time and
effort into making it clear.
But we still think it'd be
helpful to have this tool to
give you a little bit more
information about, when you do
make a Selection, what are you
expecting to get back?
And when you placed your Cursor
somewhere, what do you
expect to see?
And so, it's basically just a
simple tool where you can go
take this doc, throw in some
images, throw in some
drawings, throw in table
of contents.
And just move your Cursor
around the screen.
Kind of see how the
data changes.
Select some things, see
how the data changes.
And that will help, we hope,
guide your development efforts
when you use this feature
in your own products.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: So again,
here's that doc.
And you see, we've got the
Sidebar open on the side.
That's popped up from this menu
here, where you just hit
Show Sidebar, and then
that comes up.
And then, so right now
I'll just click here.
Right now, this is
a Cursor, right?
I don't have anything
selected.
So you see the offset from the
beginning of the paragraph
that we're in and what
type of element
we're looking at there.
And then, if I go ahead and
highlight this whole block
here, we move down
to the selection.
And we see the type of element
that the selection is in,
whether or not it's partial.
I have selected the full
paragraph here by doing that
double click.
So you see that partial
is set to false.
And then indices on where
that selection
happens, if it is partial.
So with this partial selection,
you see the start
and ending indices within
the paragraph.
ERIC KOLEDA: So, a simple little
tool, but it kind of
hopefully get you up
and running sooner
with Cursor and Selection.
We'll probably do another GDL
someday that goes deeper into
Cursors and Selections.
But for now, I think that's a
great way to get started.
Check out the blog posts.
Start playing around with
some of these samples.
Go from there.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Totally.
And in addition to that, you
can actually grab all the
source code.
Of course, you can go into the
Script Editor here, and pop
open the source code and modify
it within the doc.
But we also have this
all up on GitHub.
And that link is, again,
in the blog post.
And that's here.
So I had the Cursor Inspector
open in particular.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's also
Bibstro, as well.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yep.
So Bibstro and the Cursor
Inspector are here, in GitHub
with a little bit of ReadMe.
And you can grab all that
code from here too.
ERIC KOLEDA: So we're just
trying to make more of the
sample code available and
in a place where you
can always find it.
Sometimes, we'll publish this
doc, and you can grab the code
from there.
But maybe you'll lose
track of that.
So hopefully we're planning to
add even more samples as we
build them into this Google
Apps Script samples
repository.
And so, keep an eye on that.
You may want to bookmark
it for the future.
All right, great.
That is a little section on
Cursor and Selection.
Just to comb through some other
news you may have missed
since our last Google
Apps Unscripted.
A bunch of other recent blog
posts that we put out-- one is
that there's a new version
of Flubarru out.
Flubarru is the--
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Super cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: Super cool and
hilariously named script.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Where'd
the name come from?
ERIC KOLEDA: I have no
idea what that means.
I'll have to ask somebody.
But it's a very popular Apps
Script that teachers have been
using to do grading,
via forms.
And Dave--
he's actually a Googler who does
this just on the side.
It's not his main job.
He just loves Apps Script and
helping out teachers.
He put out a brand new version
that has new features
involved, some new features
that he listed there.
And we think teachers are
really going to love it.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Yeah, I think--
so as well, I'm a student but
I've been a TA as well.
And grading is one of the, in
fact the most frustrating part
of that job.
So I can only imagine that as a
teacher it's quite similar.
I don't think anyone really
wants to grade.
So anything that makes that
process easier can only be a
good thing.
Especially I guess now that
it's at version three and
pretty polished all that.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's
pretty exciting.
And cool.
We've had two other blog posts
recently, kind of highlighting
what some people are doing
with Apps Script.
So one here, a domain
administrator, who was tired
of creating groups within his
Google Apps domain for people
who wanted them.
And so rather than just keep
fielding emails from requests
from people, he actually made
a system using Apps Script
that allows users themselves
to basically
apply labels to threads.
And then he'll automatically
find those threads and create
a new domain group with all
the people in that thread.
So it's kind of a really simple
way where it's like,
you started a conversation
with a bunch of people.
You're like, you know what?
We're constantly adding
these same five people
to this same place.
Let's just create a group.
So it kind of takes the admin
out of the picture.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: That's
pretty cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And so that's one thing.
And then the other one down
there is Shipping Tracking.
So, someone who runs a small
jewelry business, I believe,
and needs to keep track
of all the shipments.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah.
And that's cool.
Like, I would consider setting
up something like this for my
Amazon orders, let alone
my [INAUDIBLE].
It's way cool.
So I think what he did was he
basically looked in his Gmail
inbox for these particular
shipping emails, pushed those
out to a package tracking
service.
And from that site he was able
to basically just see where
all the packages where.
The tricky part was getting the
tracking info from those
emails to the shipping
service.
And with just a quick little
Google Apps Script, he was
able to make that happen, with,
it looks like, very
little code.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's the kind of
thing, he was not using Apps
Script as a language to do
complex geo-spatial tracking.
But it's a really great
integration platform.
There's an existing service that
allows you to get this
tracking information.
So all he needed to do was pull
it out of one place and
put it into another place.
And sometimes Apps Script
is that perfect glue to
get that job done.
So do check out our blog
from time to time.
We have some great posts there,
hopefully things that
can inspire you about what you
can do with Apps Script, as
well as news about new features
that come out.
So something else that I wanted
to touch on was, we
just launched a feature
recently.
And we did a whole GDL episode
on it that you may have
missed, on importing and
exporting Google Apps Scripts.
So the Drive SDK is a separate
API that allows you to access
files from your drive.
And it has the ability to
download from your drive,
upload data to your
drive, et cetera.
Well, we recently enhanced it
to provide the ability to do
import and export of your Google
Apps Script as well.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Is that here?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
So if you go to our videos
section, you can see right at
the top there is Apps
Script Crash Course
on Import and Export.
But if you want to see the
documentation itself, just go
back to our site.
And then it's under the
Development Environment.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Ah, there it is.
ERIC KOLEDA: And then in there
we have a link for Importing
and Exporting Projects.
So, Arun, one of our colleagues,
put together a
whole bunch of great
documentation.
And he's going to add even
more samples, hopefully,
showing you essentially how you
can use the Drive SDK to
do this kind of Import
and Export
of Apps Script project's.
It's a little bit more
complicated, because you're
now writing code against
a different API.
And you're doing it on your
own local machines.
So if you're just used to
writing Apps Script code, this
is going to be a little
bit different.
You may have to use Python
or Java or Ruby.
You can use a lot different
languages with the Drive SDK,
setting up an environment,
a server.
It could be a bit more
complicated.
But that said, we think it
really opens up a lot of cool
doors for people who want to,
maybe, edit their code
offline, or download it, so that
they can check it into a
version control system.
There's a lot of different
possibilities here.
And we're excited to see
what people build.
And actually, I think just
today, I saw that one of our
users on one of the Google
Apps Script Google+
communities actually built an
Apps Script library for
importing and exporting
Apps Script code.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Oh, awesome.
That's funny.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, it's
very "Inception."
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Yeah, meta.
ERIC KOLEDA: So, you can
now use Apps Script
to export Apps Script.
Pretty crazy stuff.
So, we hope that you check out
the GDL, where they go into a
lot more detail about how this
all works, or just check out
the documentation.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah, it
looks like it's pretty
thorough here and pretty good.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh cool.
And then other GDL that we did
recently was one about the
Script Editor, kind of
like tips and tricks.
So when you write Apps
Script code,
it's all in your browser.
And we have an online editor.
And there's a little features
in there that you might not
know about--
some keyboard shortcuts, some
sort of advanced features.
So go to our Google Developers
Live page or the YouTube
channel there, on the bottom.
And you can find that
episode as well.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah, you
want to catch up on the older
episodes here.
And I thought that was a super
cool one, because I just love
keyboard shortcuts and just kind
of being on the keyboard.
And actually in terms of
importing and exporting
scripts, I would love to see
a VIM extension too, just
keeping in with the whole
keyboard thing.
Yeah, that one--
I learned a ton from that about
the Apps Script IDE, and
just ways to improve your
workflow and move a little bit
more quickly through the code
that you're writing.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, we all have other
things to do.
So squeezing out a little bit
more time certainly helps.
Very cool.
And so then lastly, before we
jump into questions, I just
want to take a little quick
pass through our Release
Notes, to kind of catch up on
some important items you may
have missed.
So, for big announcements like
brand new features, Cursor and
Selection, we'll post
those on the blog.
But we're constantly, on
a week by week basis,
introducing fixes to bugs,
or small new features.
And our Release Notes page is
where you can find out, kind
of like, what's changed.
It's linked off the bottom
of our home page, again.
And it's a great thing to check
on from time to time to
see if there's something new you
could take advantage of.
Or maybe a bug that was holding
up has now been fixed.
So the list is long.
We've done quite a number of
things since our last episode.
But just to highlight a few of
them, one of the ones that I
know people were asking for was
Commenter abilities in the
Drive Service, specifically
around Google Docs.
So, the Google Docs model allows
you to be a Viewer, an
Editor, an Owner, but
also a Commenter.
You can view it, but you
can also add comments.
And it's kind of somewhere in
between View and Edit access.
And we didn't have that ability
to add that via the
Apps Script code.
You could only do
it via the UI.
But now we can do if via
Apps Script too.
I think that's pretty cool.
Yeah, for setting up scripts,
or maybe you want to take a
document you have, and email it
out to a list and say, hey
guys, can you review?
You want to automatically
give all those
reviewers Commenter access.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Right, you
can totally put a script
together for a list of
Reviewers, pushing that out.
They become Commenters,
that kind of thing.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think that
would be pretty cool.
And then one of the things that
has been on our plate for
a long time now--
we finally got to it --was
making it so that when you
send email via Gmail app, the
emails you send appear in your
Sent folder.
So a lot of people, they
were using Apps
Script to send out emails.
But then they were kind
of never really clear.
Was it sent?
What did the texts actually
say in the end?
Who were the actual
recipients?
You could do some logging, but
it'd just be better that, if
an email came from your account,
you can see it in
your sent folder.
When that person replied, it
would be threaded nicely.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: So that
was something that
people really wanted.
And we just recently
added that in.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Were you
able to see it in your Gmail
previously, or was
it just not--
ERIC KOLEDA: Just
not even there.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: And if
someone replied, would it then
pop back into your inbox?
ERIC KOLEDA: I believe it just
was as if-- like, you'd see it
as if you had never
gotten the email.
And so you'd have it like--
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
A new thing.
ERIC KOLEDA: --bracketed
in at the bottom.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Well, that's
cool that it's now in
the great Gmail UI
and all that.
ERIC KOLEDA: So those are
some cool things.
Likewise, if we keep going down
a little bit into June, I
think some of those ones--
yeah, just some small changes
to the way some things work.
But I think in the June 3, there
was one where I wanted
to highlight.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Sure.
ERIC KOLEDA: And the
first one there.
When you would run a script
previously, it would say,
"running script", and then
the name of the script.
And then it would say, "script
finished." And sometimes what
that was doing was taking, kind
of like, the internal
names in your code and showing
them to the people that were
running your script,
which maybe
weren't always the coders.
And it just gets a
little confusing.
So we've now, just for
simplicity's sake, remove that
little piece of text--
the function name--
from that little notification
that comes
when you start a script.
Just so it says, "I'm running
a script," and "I'm done
running a script."
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Right.
And I can imagine that'll make
the lives of people using
scripts a little bit easier.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's a little
less confusing, like I'm
running what now?
So do feel free to poke around
the Release Notes and go into
more detail.
It's a great way to stay
up to date on all
these little changes.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Very cool.
And there's a lot of them.
ERIC KOLEDA: Gotcha.
All right.
So let's just keep going.
So let's get into the question
and answer now.
So, I don't know if we have
anybody live on the Hangout.
Let's check in.
Hello on the Hangout.
Any questions?
I'm not hearing anything.
All right.
Well, so, feel free
to hang around.
If you have a question,
chime in.
And we'll feel free
to get to it.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: We've got
a couple in the Moderator.
ERIC KOLEDA: So let's go.
So we do have some questions on
the Google Moderator that
we had set up earlier.
So let's take a look at those.
So we have here--
let's start from the top.
Any news about improvements
in the Apps Script IDE?
Any plans for a plug-in with
Intellij or Eclipse?
Well, as we just mentioned, we
did do a whole show about the
Apps Script IDE.
So maybe there's an improvement
that you didn't
even know about--
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Exactly.
ERIC KOLEDA: And it's been
sitting there the whole time.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Yeah, exactly.
Those keyboard shortcuts,
let me tell you.
They're great.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I think the
other thing is that we don't
have any immediate
plans to launch
plug-ins for our editors.
But with the ability to use the
Drive SDK to do import and
export, there's nothing stopping
and enterprising
person, developer, to build
their own integration with
their favorites.
So you say you're interested
in VIM--
that could be a week-end project
for you to spin up a
VIM plug-in.
So I think, if there are IDs
that people really love and
would love to do Apps
Script coding, I
would say, it's a start.
But just see if you can self
organize, like, check out the
Google+ community, see if you
get some other people maybe to
contribute, and then
go from there.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
Yeah, I know.
I would love to see those.
I just think those plug-ins
would be really cool.
And being able to edit
offline like that
would be a cool thing.
Again, that being said, I think
the Apps Script IDE is
very solid, with the
auto-completion that's there,
it's a really great way to
write Apps Script code.
Because you don't have to
worry too much about
referencing back for a specific
library, you can just
his Control Space and find the
function you're sort of
looking for right.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think that's one
of the issues that, if you
do go out and build one of these
plug-ins, you're going
to find that--
how are you going to
do auto-complete?
Right?
And then, how are you going
to run your code?
The code runs all
on the cloud.
You can't really
run it locally.
So, I think although having
offline Edit access actually
be useful in a lot of scenarios,
it's probably not
going to be as a rich or a
complete experience as using
the online IDE.
All right.
Great.
So next up, can I edit the
navigation bar from a Google
site using Apps Script?
So the answer I think is,
unfortunately, no today.
The navigation bar--
I guess it depends on
what that means.
At least most of the Google
Sites I've used, the pages in
your site are just automatically
reflected on the
left-hand side bar.
So you could add a new page or
move a page around, I believe
via the Sites app, which would
then influence the left bar.
But if you're talking about a
bar at the top, or the menu
bar when you're doing editing,
unfortunately that today
cannot be manipulated
via the Sites app.
For instance, you can add
a new menu to the
Google Docs menu bar.
But you can't do it on the
menu bar in Google Sites.
So, I guess if I didn't answer
your question, you can follow
up with us offline.
Maybe just reach out to me on
Google+, and I can give you
some more information.
OK?
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: Great.
So next up, can I edit and
create a forum on the fly with
Apps Script?
Well, yes you can, is
the short answer.
So this was actually the subject
of my talk at Google
I/O this year.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah,
I watched that one.
That was really cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: And so that was
the ability to do Google
Forms, manipulation
via the Forms app.
So it's a whole new service in
Google Apps Script that allows
you to not just manipulate or
read the contents of a Form,
but actually even create
new Forms on the fly.
So one of the things I demoed
was the ability to use a
Google Form to create
a Google Form.
So, I would fill out one Form.
And then when I filled it out,
an Apps Script would run that
would trigger and create a brand
new Form and then send
that out again.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
It was for quiz
generation, is that right?
ERIC KOLEDA: It was, yeah.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: You could
specify your quiz questions.
And then it would spit out
the next quiz as a
Google Form, right?
ERIC KOLEDA: So, I think
Flubarru is probably a bit
more robust and made
for longer quizzes.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: The one here that
I was focusing on was
something where, you just
taught a subject.
You know, I'd really love
to know if kids got it.
You just type one quick
question, hit Send.
It goes to the whole class.
They fill out the answer.
You get all the responses.
It's a five minute process.
And so, it was using Forms
to create Forms.
So it's definitely possible to
create Forms with Apps Script.
And we think it actually
can lead to
some really cool things.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah, and
it sounds like definitely on
the fly, if you can get it
running that quickly.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, great.
And the other one here
we have is--
oh, we already answered
that one about the ID.
All right, great.
So, let's check back in
on the Hangout, and
see if anybody there.
No one's there.
All right.
Well, that's all the questions
we have here on the Moderator.
I'm just going to check
Google+ as well.
And let's see if we have any
comments here that are
interesting.
It looks like we did have
some problems with
the Livestream today.
So we apologize for that, if you
were watching live, or you
didn't get a chance to.
I'm sorry about that.
So we will post this
recording .
And if you're hearing me
say this, you were
watching the recording.
So, I don't see any
other comments.
An how about Christian?
Do you have anything else to
add, you'd like to say, before
we say goodbye?
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
No, not really.
I think, yeah, I mean, it's
just, as someone who's really
come into Apps Script
for the first time,
it's been very cool.
Over the past, I guess, month
or so, it's been very cool
learning all the different
features and hearing things.
Yeah, feedback from the--
it's very easy for me to ask
questions, because I've got
Eric here and the rest of the
team sitting across from me.
But, I know I've had
a ton of questions.
And I think, getting involved,
reaching out when you're a bit
confused is definitely
a good thing to do.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Having
been there myself.
ERIC KOLEDA: So if you do have
questions, coming to these
Apps Unscripted is a great
way to get them answered.
But we only do them about
once a month.
So, in the meantime, we have a
support page on our website
you can check out.
And we basically say, if you're
asking a very technical
question, a detailed question,
we have a Stack Overflow tag,
where a lot of people go there
and ask questions and have
some really great answers.
So recommend using
Stack Overflow.
And if you have a broad
question, you just want to
know, generally, can
I do something?
Generally, what's the best
way to do something?
We recommend maybe looking at
some Google+ communities that
are out there for Google Apps
Script, where there are some
really dedicated passionate
users who have a lot of good
experience as well.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI: Yeah, like
the education one seems pretty
active and very cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
A whole community just on Apps
Script for education.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
That's awesome.
ERIC KOLEDA: Great.
Well, with that, I think we're
going to wrap it up for today.
Thanks everybody who tuned in,
or failed to tune in but is
watching it now.
And we'll hopefully work
out all the kinks
for our next episode.
Once again, my name's Eric.
CHRISTIAN MOSCARDI:
And I'm Christian.
ERIC KOLEDA: And we'll
see you next time.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]